[Music]
big week for Queen Elizabeth you've been
reading about this okay
this week in London Queen Elizabeth wore
earplugs at the concert honoring her
60th year on the throne 60 years on the
throne and she wore earplugs
yeah the earplugs weren't for the lab
music but because Prince Charles kept
screaming died already
won't she just died I was horrified -
I'm with you on that one
Vice President Joe Biden's wife Jill
Biden has written a children's book
isn't that nice
it's called green eggs and help my
husband won't stop talking doesn't even
rhyme there's nobody it's a really bad
book kids are gonna love it
did you hear what Facebook is paying
their interns did you hear this I did
yeah it's ridiculous it's been reported
that Facebook pays their interns seventy
four thousand dollars a year in a
related story our interns get paid in
warm orange Shasta
oh you like that
[Music]
but why are you happy that I treat them
for what an inherently mean bunch you
are
oh good get it yeah do you kick them -
yes I do this week glenn beck mocked
vogue editor-in-chief Anna Wintour for
her aristocratic accent and for being
the devil yet a comment sent shockwaves
throughout the entire town of who cares
Ville USA it's a story that pleases no
one any coffee drinkers here I can tell
by the way you're clapping a new study
claims that coffee drinkers live longer
than people who don't drink coffee of
course coffee drinkers waste all those
extra years waiting in line at Starbucks
so it comedian Bill Maher has purchased
a minority share of the New York Mets
yeah Marv says he's changing the team
name from the Mets to the smirking
atheists
I just want to see the uniform and the
smirking atheists are taking the video
and here they go right after only 10
weeks on the market only 10 weeks Taco
Bell has sold 100 million Doritos Locos
Tacos yeah today the CEO of Taco Bell
said he is pleased while the CEO of
Charmin toilet paper said he's ecstatic
[Applause]
did you this crowd go crazy when I
mentioned the Doritos Locos hot listen I
come out here every night and I
mentioned things like America freedom
equality for all yeah I get polite
applause then I just have yes taco sir
you're not that was crazy
that's the most happy I've ever seen a
crowd I've got a try one are they a
sponsor oh I did try one
[Applause]
[Music]
and what that thing was was very good
the thing is my favorite thing the thing
that helps its from the company that
buys at time for us is my favorite thing
the devil's watching yeah keep talking
more loco have you had one have you had
the Doritos Locos Tacos knothead oh man
we're going together
no there should be a truckload of them
coming tomorrow oh that never happens to
us I mentioned appliance all the time we
don't get squat right you and I are
getting on a bicycle built for two
tomorrow I'm going to get Locos Tacos
burritos
[Applause]